[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHARON ORLOPP: All right,
thank you and welcome.
Please appreciate Thuhang.
She's going to share
her story with us.
But let's first give her a
big round of appreciation.
[APPLAUSE]
THUHANG TRAN: I would
like to walk you
through for the
journey, the journey
that where [INAUDIBLE]
have the hope
and determination for
nonstop reinvention
from throughout my life.
First thing first,
that I'm Thuhang Tran.
I was lucky that
[INAUDIBLE] to Sharon,
and that's how the story
coming to you today.
So, this is the
journey that have been
go through for till I was born.
And when I struck for
the polio and also, I
mean, during the Vietnam,
the Saigon fall in 1975.
The first thing is,
infusion of hope.
So, hope is the only way that
build up and be with me when
I was--
at least in my memories have
been formed and remember.
So, I was born as a normal
child, run and walking.
And then by the time I am
two and a half years old,
I got contracted with polio.
And later on when I
came to the state,
the doctor diagnosis
as a post polio.
So, that is the
time that when I was
born as the the time of
during the Vietnam War as well
is hidden time.
But during the time when I got--
my parents found out that I had
polio, and they very frustrated
and also devastated.
So my dad had been searching
and seeking for all my treatment
for myself.
Like, been through acupuncture
and also like electronic shock
to make to activate
their nerves,
that maybe can help me to walk.
But after so many attempts
with some different kind
of treatment, I'm paralyzed
from the waist down.
And, to further to get, at
least have something for myself,
so my dad did further research.
So finally he found out
there's another program that
can help children
had polio can come
to Germany to get treatment.
So I got approval,
the paperwork,
for to go to Germany by myself
as a five-year-old child,
and to get treatments to surgery
and then physical therapy
so I can walk normally.
And the paperwork is approval
for, I think June 1975.
So with that, my mom and myself
as [INAUDIBLE],, because I'm
excited that I got the new
clothes with the luggage so
I can be travel, because
I didn't know that I
would be travel by myself.
However, I just excited I got
new clothes and travel, right?
I never-- I couldn't imagine
that I would travel by myself.
So, it's the hope that
I will be got treatment
and can be walk
normal again, have
been turned upside down
when the fall of Saigon
come in April 30, 1975.
So I think in the
video that we say
that's just the test moment for
all of South Vietnamese people
because that the communists
took over the South.
So when during that time my
dad has been based further
from the house, because we
lived in city, Saigon city.
And my medic was based at
[INAUDIBLE] Air Force Base.
And we lost contact
after two days.
And then when we
heard, because we
live very close to the
[VIETNAMESE] Airport,
so there's a lot of
bombing an artillery,
all the shadows over our roof.
And it just get like that.
And all the neighbor
having us to dig it
up the bunker, temporary
bunker, by our kitchen floor.
So, we live in the
bunker for about two,
three days with a very limited
food and run out water,
and it's very hot and humid.
And I was like, at
that time I just
didn't know what's going on.
And my brother and
sister was tired
and my young uncle was scare.
And one time I remember that,
because it's so hot so we all
decided to just get up and then
just stay in the living room.
Then when we heard
the siren went off,
then we all jumped-- my brother,
sister, and everyone jump,
right?
My mom couldn't got
me down to the bunker.
She just throw me to my uncle
and my brother, catch me!
So those are the
moment that just
stuck engraved to my memory.
Then April 30, the
North Vietnamese army
took over the south.
And they changed all the names
name-- all the city names--
completely.
Even alleys-- in Asia,
especially Vietnam-- we
have a lot of small
alleys-- we have it.
Residents live there.
So they and every
single street-- alley--
to honor the North
Vietnamese leader.
So with that, then
they order all of us--
everyone who have a relative
that's working for South Army
Vietnam--
to burn all the paperwork
or pictures related to them.
So I was secretly hiding some
of the pictures of my dad
and some of the paperwork
related to him--
and just hide it in some of
the dirt around the bunker.
And then of course, my mom
burned all other paperwork
related to my dad.
And a few months later, we
found out, from my dear friend,
that he witnessed that my
dad's helicopter crashed
into the [INAUDIBLE] River.
And his luggage just bounced
out from the helicopter.
So he took back to us
with his belongings.
And of course, it's
the war-- right?
There's a lot of other
people-- lost their relative,
their loved one, and maybe
lost contact completely.
So we accepted with that.
And more on, we had the funeral,
without his body, for him.
So when I sat in the church,
I'd look at his picture.
And I said, without his body,
maybe God just lets him-- maybe
he's somewhere else.
So that hope infused
me during that time
that I believed that my
dad lived somewhere else--
he not die.
So at his funeral-- because
Vietnamese tradition--
we wear a white band
right [INAUDIBLE]
to mourn him for three years.
And we move on with our lives.
And the communists,
of course, took
over a lot of people houses,
and people became homeless just
over the night.
They live under the bridge.
And they force people--
woman, children-- to the famine.
Most likely, those famine
areas was a [INAUDIBLE]..
So that a lot of people
lost their arms, legs,
because there were the mines--
had been blown up.
And like any other child,
we ate rotten food,
was being hungry for many days.
And I got malnutrition badly.
So my stomach lay
bloated all the time,
because of the rotten food.
And it's pain all the time.
So whenever it's
pain, my grandma
had to tap on my stomach
to have it calm down.
So when I mention my grandma--
that is the picture
in the middle.
That's my grandma.
She wears a traditional
dress right there.
So because my mom and
my brother and sister
have been forced to
go to the [INAUDIBLE]..
Because I'm the youngest
and I was handicapped,
I stayed with my
grandma and my aunt.
During that time that I saw
my grandma and my aunt--
they're really sad.
So I determine-- how I can be
happy and be surviving more?
That way, I can help
my grandma and my aunt
to go through the tough
times, because they
been through the difficult
time as myself as well.
So I tried to be positive.
That's what hope
continued to help
me go through those struggles.
And I just see the picture there
that I'm a skinny girl with--
at that time, I think, I was
7 or 8 or something like that.
And when I start school,
after a few months,
my mom couldn't harvest
anything from the farming,
because the government
didn't assist anything.
My mom did the
farming by bare hands
and with the help
of the neighbor.
So I remember one time that
I've been hungry so many days.
And my mom brought back
the bag of corn on the cob.
And I kept eating corn on the
cob for I don't know how many--
until I became sick.
And after that, corn's
still my go-to food.
And I still love it till now.
But the rest of the
other food, I've
just never touched it again.
And because my mom didn't
have money or anything
to have the soil or
fertilize-- so she
decided to took my brother
and sister back to the city.
And my house-- very small, with
three families living there.
Actually, two families-- my aunt
and her two twin sons, my mom,
my brother and sister,
and myself and my grandma.
So it's very tiny.
And we just sleep every corner
that the house allowed to.
So my mom had do all kinds
job to survive and make sure
bring food to raising us
and my brother and sister,
even though they are
teenagers at that time--
but still working
to help my mom.
And everyday, in the
afternoon, when I saw
the neighbor kid went
home after the school.
And I just say, oh my gosh!
What's going on there?
They're so happy and
lively and have fun.
So I begging my mom--
Mom, I want to go to school.
And my mom, because she didn't
want me to been through all
the teasing, the
bullying from the kids--
because during that
time the government--
or the people in general--
saw handicapped people
as useless human beings.
The handicapped people
is like a burden--
burden to the society,
burden to their own family,
burden to the people
surrounding them.
So after [INAUDIBLE] that
I wanted to make sure
my mom at least feels secure
that I can be OK with school.
So I start school
very late age--
8 or something like that.
And after a few
months, my teacher
helping me to start first grade.
So because of the mindset from
the people and government--
the school didn't have--
the communist government
didn't assist
handicapped people--
encourage them to go to school.
So the school didn't have
any ramps or accessibility
for the handicapped people.
It's all stairs.
So when I was little, my mom
carried me on her back upstairs
to the third floor--
carried me down,
everyday like that.
And when I get older,
a little bigger,
and I got heavier for sure--
so I didn't want my
mom have to do that.
So I had to reinvent myself--
how I can manage around.
When I was little, I crawled.
So my arm was my leg.
And my legs dragging
on the floor.
So all my trousers have
the holes in my knees.
So my mom kept patching
different type animals
to make it fun for me.
So when I at school,
at that time,
I reinvented-- a found a way
how I can manage around myself.
So I sat up and used my
hands to move my knee.
But I sat at the down level.
When it came to the
state, the doctor
observed me moving
around like that.
And he called it duck walking.
So that's what I squatting
for years I went to school--
climb up stairs and come
stairs like that every day.
And so I did the school.
And not because of that
would be prevented me to
don't have fun--
don't have fun or hang
out with my friends.
So that's what I--
when I get home, I played
with my neighbor kids--
all kind of games
that they have.
And I just squatting like that--
just have fun with them.
At same time at
school, one time, I
figured out a way how I can
slide down to save time,
So usually, at school, they
have built the handrail
around the stairway.
So one time, I just
asked one of my friends--
because that friend helped me
carry my bag everyday upstairs
and downstairs.
So I just created
some kind of fun.
I said, let's do
some sort of fun.
And we just slide
down like that.
One day, I slide down.
And then by the time we hit the
basement of the first floor--
and there, the
principal stood there.
And she looked at me and
said, you're in trouble.
So she called my
mom to the office.
And all my mom got is
blaming that my mom didn't
know how to raise
me, because I'm not
supposed to do that at school.
So I promised my mom
that I will be good.
I don't want my mom to be
insulted from the school
principal or anyone.
Because I sat there.
I heard them just insult my mom.
So again, with that,
when I get home,
I said, no, I have
to excel at school.
I have to be good.
So that's where I can show
people that with education, I
will have better life.
So that's what I did--
so five years later, there
was a big life change for us.
One day, my uncle with one
gentleman came to our house
and say that my
father was alive.
And he lived in
San Antonio, Texas.
I was like exciting and crying.
And at that time, my mom--
her business getting better.
So she's selling rice, pen
by pen, back to the people,
so that means she
can gain some money
and then can raise us right.
So I asked the neighbor
to come to the market
to make sure that my mom
and my sister come home.
And by the time my mom
and my sister get home
and we all cry happy--
and the whole neighborhood
very happy that my dad is still
alive at that time.
And then, because of the
control of the government--
the communists--
every single letter that we
wrote to our dad and our dad
wrote to us-- it
took six months,
because every single letter had
to be opened and inspected--
make sure that there's
no word or anything
against the government.
However, my dad very happy
that he found us and locate us.
And then he asked-- the second
letter that he sent to us--
asking us to send him picture
and birth certificate.
And at that time, my mom said,
we didn't have any pictures.
That's when I said, Mom, no.
We have some.
So my mom said,
where'd you get it?
I said-- the picture--
I didn't listen to you.
I already hidden them.
So she said, oh, my god!--
all these years!
I said, yes, Mom.
So that's what those-- at least
pictures, because at that time
I didn't want to forget my dad.
I didn't want to lose
his image or his picture.
Because at that time, we
thought that he's already died.
So the length of the paper
process took forever--
took for forever.
We separate for 15 years.
And then we filed that
the paper about 10 years.
So during the time that
we waiting for the paper
that we can come to the State--
so at that time, between the US
and the Vietnamese government--
there is very still--
intense, even though
they have a program
they call ODP, if you
heard about those.
That means Operation
Departure Program--
that they allow for
all the servicemen who
worked with the
previous government
can come sponsor their
family to the United States.
And between 1980--
that was the time--
1980.
So between 1980 to 1989, because
of the length of the process,
we didn't know if we
could reunite with my dad.
So my brother escaped
the country by boat.
So probably, you can
have friends and people--
the Vietnamese people-- if they
say, I escaped the country.
I came here by boat people,
that's what happened.
And this was also a
very darkest moment
for the Vietnamese
people as well.
Because a lot of people
has been escaped by boat.
And they sacrificed their life.
They didn't know if they can
come to the United States.
Some of them die in the ocean,
but just because of the hope
that, someday, they
can find freedom.
So that's what--
during that time.
And back to--
finally, we continue
to move on with our
lives, because we
didn't know that we were going
to be see our dad, right?
And after three attempts--
my brother-- two attempts
to escape the country
by boat-- my brother got
caught into a prison.
And my father had to
send some money back
through the black market.
Because at that time,
there's no relation
between US and
Vietnamese government.
So my father had sent money
through the black market,
so people can find a
way to get us the money.
My mom used those money to pay
for the expense for my brother
to escape the country and, also,
to bribe the policeman that can
release my brother from prison.
So after three attempts
that didn't succeed,
we moved on with our
life by do all kinds job.
And during that
time, I just again
reinvent myself-- how
I can learn a new skill
and to survive as well.
So I learn different
things-- do different jobs.
I have done all kinds of
jobs, like sit there--
do embroidery for the
clothes and, also,
even making the car tire--
that's what I sit there, do one
string at a time on the rubber.
So one time, my hand just
bleeding and calloused,
because of that.
And--
SHARON ORLOPP: We need
to switch to the US.
THUHANG TRAN: Yes.
SHARON ORLOPP: We're
running low on time.
THUHANG TRAN: So with that--
1989-- I think it's summer time.
Can you go to the next slide?
We received the
letter at US embassy.
It say, congratulation.
Now, you come to
have an interview.
And you can come to
the United States.
So my life changed.
And my family's life changed
again, one more time.
And the new life in the US--
it was a first.
It was a happy ever after.
Because after 15
years-- we separated--
we was able to
unite with my dad.
However, this was challenging--
culture shock--
completely at first.
And because we lived
apart for 15 years,
there's a lot of differences
in our thoughts, in our minds,
and even how we communicate--
differences between
my mom and my father.
My mom think or act in East.
My dad think or
act in a West way.
So they are completely opposite.
Same for us as well--
language-- completely
new language.
And we struggle with that--
struggle in our own family
with our life, struggle
with the culture shock,
and also facing with
the language barrier.
And then at the same time, my
dad had bought health insurance
for me, that mean prepare for
me when I come to the States,
so I can have surgery.
So that's what, in
the fall, happened--
the winter of 1989, I had
a surgery for my knee.
I spent two years for
physical therapy intensively--
learned how to walk again and
learned ESL at the same time.
The first time ever I stood
up from the ground level
to the level that I can stand--
I could stand--
I could feel that there's
some chemical in my brain--
changed--
changed completely.
Because of I was in the
ground level for so long.
And I could see the expression
from my mom and my dad.
They was crying.
But they happy.
And because of one
income, my father had--
he signed a paper
that he guarantee
that, when his sponsor the
family to the United States,
he will guarantee that he cover
for all the expense for us.
We won't get any assist from the
government or any kind program
that the government provides.
So my brother and my sister--
working to help him out.
And I, during the
time of two years--
physical therapy and then
went to school at night
with my sister.
After work, she came
home and picked me up.
And both of us learning ESL,
English as a Second Language.
And technology-- technology
came to me at first because--
the first time I saw my dad
put the computer hardware--
he built a computer
from scratch.
At that moment--
that inspired me.
That's completely ooh and ahh!
At that moment.
I said, how you put the
hardware piece together--
it becomes that
computer workstation?
So when I finished my
ESL, I took the class
as an electrical engineer.
So I enrolled the
first semester.
And after one semester,
I said, oh my god--
how the circuits can
put together like this!
And I feel like, I
don't think that's me.
Because I feel, at that
time-- so dry to me.
I want something creative way.
And I share that with my dad.
And he said, well,
if you not so sure,
why don't you just
go to your school
and talk with the counselor?
That's what happened.
When I talked to the counselor,
the counselor said, get me
the catalog with
all the computers.
And at that time, I really
liked to become a computer
graphic design, because I
want to create something
very creative way.
Unfortunately, because we didn't
have enough money for my dad
to send me to UT Austin--
that's where they offered
computer graphic design.
So I end up studied computer
science as my major,
because I drove
every day one hour.
I got out the house
6:00 AM in the morning
and didn't get home until,
like, 10:00, 11:00 PM,
because I spent the
whole time at school
and worked there
as part-time job.
And that's what I keep joking.
I say-- and I
[INAUDIBLE] as well.
I say, ramen noodles
is my best friend.
So that's what-- I
ate that in library--
anywhere.
But it's a great
investment for education.
Because like I mentioned
earlier, with me, when
I was little, to
be better, i always
find out that
education will lead us
to different type
opportunities-- opportunities
and a better life.
So being said that, I would
like to share with you just
a high-level-- key
level-- here's what,
throughout my life and
throughout my professional
career--
these are the three
things that, maybe, I hope
that you can take away for you.
Embrace change with
the survival mindset.
So through my life--
through the war,
poverty, and then
crawling on the ground
and then sit up and then
after stand up
after my surgery--
I always have to be
that way to survive.
Had to survive that-- and then
you don't have to do much.
Just think about different
perspectives in life.
Reinvent-- most likely, I think,
in our professional world--
we can say, problem solving.
People love to
solve the problem.
But it's not like
rocket science.
It just happens to your
day-to-day activities and even
at work as well--
how you're facing with--
interfacing with people,
with your co-workers,
and when the
production issues come.
What is the problem?
How to solve it?
Good calls-- right.
So that-- our activity--
day-to-day activities--
and seeing we are [INAUDIBLE]
and working in professional
world, throughout the years--
and I was lucky that I
had the great mentor, just
like [INAUDIBLE]
and Sharon here.
And now Sharon have been--
that is-- I believe in fate.
It just happened.
It's just been in the fate that
I met Sharon and we partnered
to wrote the book.
And that's what this is.
I said, establish your identity.
How do you especially
focus on your strength?
And it took me a while
for me to figure out
how I can excel at work
and what I will be good at.
That's through the session
that I had with my mentor.
They helped me.
They say, well, you're
good at technical.
Why don't you just stay
in technical software
and then build up from there?
That's what I built
up over the years.
And here I come today.
And thus I learned.
And like I shared with
Angelo this morning,
every single where I go--
even this event--
I learned a lot--
how people interact?
And learn-- how do
people organize things?
So thank you so
much for your time.
And thank you so much for
listening to the story.
And I hope that you
enjoy reading the story.
And maybe it can relate
to some sort of--
whenever you struggle
or have a bad day
or you hit the rock bottom,
just thing about that it will be
hope always--
infusing hope and full of hope.
And someday, it will get better.
SHARON ORLOPP: All right,
let's appreciate Thuhang.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: We can take
about five or so minutes
to answer any questions
from the audience.
It's a great book--
incredibly inspiring.
When you wrote it,
it was very intimate.
You had to reveal a
lot about your family.
How does your dad and your
family feel about the book?
THUHANG TRAN: At first,
especially my dad--
he was reluctant.
He was reluctant that he didn't
want to start writing the book.
The reason why-- most
likely, this reminded him
with all the bad memories.
He saw a lot of his
friends during the war die.
And it's so painful.
And this happened to me too--
because a lot of emotion.
Even now, when I say
about it, I still
carry those emotions with me.
But when Sharon talked to me
about it and that I should--
I talked to him a few days.
But we have to face it
somehow, one way or the other.
We have to let it out.
And after that, he
agreed that, OK,
we can write a story about it.
That's when Sharon came
to Bentonville, Arkansas.
And she sat down and
interviewed with us.
So that's why we overcome it.
And my mom and my
brother and sister--
they said, excited about it.
They're really happy that
their story and our story
just come to light and at
least share with everyone,
that's how we've been through,
especially after the Vietnam
War.
And there wasn't a lot
of people outside Vietnam
know about what the
life and how we lived
under the communist rules--
how we facing those.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for sharing
your very inspiring story.
I wanted to ask you,
what would your message
be today for people who now
live under oppressive regimes,
like the Viet Cong?
How would you instill
hope within them
that, someday,
things could change
and they may have a happy life?
THUHANG TRAN: That's
a great question.
Again, you mentioned the hope--
and I hope that whoever--
they still live under
communism, not only Vietnam,
but other countries as well--
they need to continue
to have a purpose--
their life purpose, not give up.
Even though that is under
communism country or any other
government, you need to
have a focus and find out,
what is the meaning of their
life and how they can make
small acts-- can
impact other people--
and don't lose hope or
lose our focus on that--
always seeking for a purpose.
MODERATOR: OK,
and now we'll move
to the second part of the talk.
Sharon--
SHARON ORLOPP:
All right-- great.
MODERATOR: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
SHARON ORLOPP: Let's appreciate
Thuhang one more time.
THUHANG TRAN: Thank you so much.
SHARON ORLOPP: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right-- good morning.
Good afternoon.
Thank you for coming and
hearing Thuhang's story.
I just want to spend a
few minutes with you,
talking about the
power of storytelling.
Because stories connect us.
They create that burning
desire to learn about others.
And every single one
of us have a story.
A lot of times, we make
assumptions about people
when we meet and see them.
And human beings have that story
that create that connection.
And so learning that
story is powerful currency
for understanding each other
and creating that inspiration
and getting that hope--
and understanding the
resilience of human beings.
So I'm just going to share
with you my personal story.
My parents were married
at the tender age of 19.
And I often say that the path
to the Chief Diversity Officer
role at Walmart started
long before I was born.
It started with my parents and
what their lives were like.
So much to the disappointment
of both sets of my grandparents,
my parents decide
to get married.
They were from very different
religious backgrounds
and very different
socioeconomic backgrounds.
And so, as I grew up, I listened
to very negative comments
when we'd get together
with our relatives.
My family on my father's
side were very disappointed
that my father chose my mother.
My mother's side-- they
thought my father's family
was arrogant and out of touch.
So we always heard
these negative things.
And I don't know
about your family,
but when our family'd
get together,
they'd just tell it the way it
is, regardless of how negative
it was or bad.
So my parents made a very
purposeful parenting decision
to move away from
relatives, because they
wanted to stop that negative
stereotypes of comments
that occurred.
So I grew up believing
that you should never
live near your relatives.
So we moved thousands
of miles away.
And we only saw them
because we had to see them.
But that experience
with my parents
made them very strong advocates
of the Civil Rights movement
and the Women's Rights movement.
So they made another
parenting decision.
When I was 12 years
old, they moved us
to a neighborhood that
was predominantly African
American and Hispanic.
So we moved to
this neighborhood.
And we were not welcome.
So we had our yard set on fire.
Our home was vandalized
several times.
My parents owned a small
landscaping business
that was also vandalized.
But I was never afraid.
I was 12 years old.
And I just wanted
to make friends.
I wanted to know,
who am I going to sit
with on the school bus every
single day when I go to school?
And so our family lived in
that neighborhood for 30 years.
And what it taught me is that
we're all more similar than we
are different.
We all want to be respected.
We want to be included.
And we want to be valued.
And so that created in me
this core belief that we all
deserve respect and inclusion.
And that's what led
me to all my work
in diversity and inclusion.
But it started with my parents
and what they did for me.
We're going talk a
little bit about why
stories are so important.
And some of it is because
they're so memorable.
We'll go to the next slide.
You're always going
to remember the story.
You may not remember
the data or the facts.
But you're going to
remember those stories that
stick with you.
A lot of things that
Thuhang shared today,
you're going to go home and
share with other people,
because it really
reminds you of that.
And when you think
about things at work
and you're presenting
pitches or ideas
or thinking about-- how do
you put it in a story format
that people remember?
And I know, Google's
big on data.
I know that.
Math and science are
really important.
Logic's important.
But there's also that
emotional content.
And stories are
emotion in motion.
So how do you link
a story to what
you're trying to sell at work
and make it more understandable
and more relatable?
I think it's important, because
stories touch the heart.
And when you touch
the heart, you
change the way people think.
And you change the behaviors.
So we'll go the next slide.
And it talks about the
different types of stories.
So when you're telling
stories, particularly
at work or at events, there's
a couple of different genres.
And you'll hear leaders that
share them this way too.
So one of the main
stories is who am I?
So when there's
a new leader that
comes to a group,
a lot of times,
you'll hear who they are,
what's important to them,
life experiences
that they've had.
Or they may talk
about why I'm here.
What's my purpose?
What do I hope to do?
They'll talk about
values and action--
what their core values are and
how they demonstrate those.
Then, also-- vision.
And then there's
teaching stories.
So what I'm going to close with
is a vision and action story.
So I've told you a
lot about growing up
and my passion around
diversity and inclusion.
So we'll go to the next slide.
And this is what I call
"The Swimming Pool" story.
So I lived in
Arkansas for 12 years,
while I worked with Walmart.
And my whole life,
I've been passionate
about diversity and inclusion.
I feel like my parents did
an incredible job, moving us
to the neighborhood
where we looked different
than everybody else.
So I've wanted to do the
same with my children.
And so we've done a lot of
diversity immersion trips.
We invite a lot of very
different people to our homes.
Four times a year, I used
to invite about 200 people
to our home from Walmart who
were from different countries
and different backgrounds.
And I was always very
purposeful on what we did.
But my main message to my
kids has always been, speak up
and speak out.
If you see something that's not
right, do something about it--
right?
Speak up.
And speak out.
That's what everybody
is obligated to do.
So one day in Arkansas, I'm
at a community swimming pool.
It's Memorial Day weekend.
And I have my 12-year-old
daughter with me.
And she's a good swimmer.
So I'll start with that.
So she jumps into the pool.
And I lay down on a lawn
chair and go to sleep.
That's bad parenting.
But there is a lifeguard.
And my daughter
is a good swimmer.
And I needed a break
from a long week at work.
So I'm sleeping.
I'm kind of dozing in and out.
And I hear this man yell,
why don't you morons get out
of the pool?!
Now, when we had walked
into the pool area,
all of the children in
the pool were white,
except for two
African-Americans.
So I heard that man yell that.
I kind of woke up.
I sat up.
And I looked in the pool.
And I didn't see the
African-American children.
So I motioned my daughter over.
And I said, what just happened?
And she reiterated
what the man had said.
So in that moment, I
have a lot going on.
Am I going to do what I've told
my children for years and years
about speak up and speak out?
Or am I going to be silent?
And this is in a community--
I don't know the
man that yelled it.
I don't know anybody
else at the pool.
What am I going to do?
And so I thought about,
what am I going to do?
And I decided that I was going
to address the man separately,
after the holiday
weekend was over.
So on Tuesday, after
Memorial Day weekend,
I drove to the
swimming pool area.
And it was only me and
him that were there.
And I hadn't told
my husband or people
at work where I was going to.
But I walk into this building.
He's sitting by this desk.
I said, hey, I want to
talk to you about what
happened on Saturday?
I said, did you say, why don't
you morons get out of the pool?
And he jumps up from the desk.
He says, are you
calling me a racist?!
And my first thought
was, nobody knows
I'm in this building
with this man by myself.
And I thought long and
hard about-- how do I
reply to his question?
So I said, I'm not
calling you a racist.
But I'm concerned
about how it made
all the children and everybody
feel when you yelled that.
So he proceeded to tell me that
he calls Hispanics "morons."
He calls women "morons."
He was what I would call an
equal employment offender.
He let me know, that's
his approach on life.
So I tried to explain
my point of view.
He tried to explain
his point of view.
We ended the
conversation with neither
of us agreeing with each
other's point of view.
So two years later, I went back
to that pool with my daughter.
It had been two years since
I'd been at that pool.
My daughter and I walk in.
It was another holiday weekend.
We walk in.
He says, you-- you--
I know what you do for a living.
I don't know how he found that
out-- probably through Google.
But he said, you-- you--
I know what you do for a living.
He said, I want to thank you.
I want to thank you for having
that conversation with me.
He said, I haven't called
anybody a moron since.
And I said, well, you and
I are always connected,
because of that conversation.
So that's a values
and action story.
And I think that's what
we all have to do--
is determine what
our core values are.
And how do we live it?
And then, how do we share
their stories about it?
So I'm going to click to
the second-to-last slide,
just to close up.
So what I want you to do
is always share your story
about inclusion.
What we did today, it's
a great icebreaker.
It's something you can
do at team meetings,
you can do at events.
But find out people's stories.
Have curiosity
about other people.
Find out what their story
is, and share your story.
And then look for
those moments that
are teaching moments
or learning moments
that you can share with people
that also have an underlying
theme around respect
and inclusion for all.
And then, have a point of view.
And then speak up
and speak out when
you see things that are wrong.
But Thuhang and I want to
thank you for your time today.
We really appreciate
you having us here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Thank you.
THUHANG TRAN: OK, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]